[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 20th
episode of my chest strap series in this
episode I am going to show you one of
the high profile trap in the
Frankenstein and Dracula gambit from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following model E 4 E Phi and
here white can choose either of this
moon let's say in this game
white continue with Vienna Mordor Knight
to c3 and after Knight to f6
he played Bishop to c4 now the gambit
start with Knight captures efore but
before we look at it the important point
I like to highlight here that if you
oppor and continue with other moves such
as Knight to c6 Bishop to c5 or the
Moody 6 then the setup I am going to
recommend is you continue with d3 and
then quick f4 which gives you a superior
version of Kings gambit structure and in
all this lines white get tremendous
attack on the black King okay
Knight captures efore so black has
destroyed the white center and if white
continue with either the move Knight
captures efore or Bishop to f7 then in
those circumstances black get a very
good game but not white is more trickier
and he wants to play this dangerous
Frankenstein Dracula gambit
starting with Queen to h5 so idea is
very simple what is attacking to soft
spot and he is going to gain his piece
as well as pawn back in near future from
here onwards the main line continued
with Knight to d6 so black is not only
defending on f7
but this night is also checking on c4
bishop
kindly note that here if white foolishly
continue with Queen captures ePHI then
after Queen to e7 Queen captures a seven
Bishop captures a seven and the move
Bishop to b3 black has instantly
equalized the game and why doesn't have
enough advantage as a first player so
accordingly the base response goes here
with Bishop to b3 keeping the tension
and giving black an opportunity to go
wrong now if you check this position in
online database you will find out that
there are two popular choice by the
black which I have highlighted here
amongst them we are going to see Knight
to c6 in this video however if we open
and continue with Bishop to d7 then I
have attached a model game in the PGN
which will give you a very good idea how
to get a good position against it okay
and Knight to c6 defending on e5 pawn
and I must say at first sight
this mu looks more natural as not only
black is developing a piece but saving
his extra pawn especially people who
don't know the theory they will
routinely churn out this move in fact
there are approximately 900 games played
in the database which continue with this
dubious moon yes that's right knight c6
is a big time in accuracy and the trap
is set right here as white is going to
win in almost all the variations the
trap users start with this tremendous
move Knight to be fine hahaha so it has
a very simple idea he wants to play
Knight captures d6 check and checkmate
the black King with Queen
seven well obviously black is not going
to that much cooperating so accordingly
the bass response goes as follow g6
counter attacking the Queen Queen to f3
still maintaining the pressure on the f7
which Knight to d6 check has been
renewed here black has two choices
Knight to f5 or f5 but as confirmed by
modern engines
neither of them give any satisfaction
result to the black and the first move
fr which is in fact highest Lee played
in this position but I'm afraid this is
not a good choice by black as after the
simple move Queen to defy looking at
juicy up 7 square once again with a
check on d6 so that means black responds
his force black has to defend f7 with
either Queen to e7 or up 6 and in both
the case white has this simple check and
after King to d8 and Knight captures
aged just within 10 moves of the game
Whitey's rock up when obviously this
Knight is not going to come out but at
least in almost all lines white get an
exchange and with some accurate and
careful play this position can be easily
converted into the full point
the second move Knight to f5 is not a
good solution either as the simple
response yep g4 hahaha
and that knight cannot move as there is
a mate on f7 well you might think hang
on
but what about a6 counter-attacking
white knight but actually here the fun
start with G captors fi and after a
captures B Phi F captures g6 again and
again looking at AB 7 made and when
black defend this threat we have the
moon she captures f7 check King to d8
Knight to e2 preventing Black Knight 2
coming on d4 and after the whole
transaction it turns out that not only
black King has been misplaced but at
this position white is a clear pawn of
and that is on the seventh rank that's
it guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
amazing high profile trap in the
Frankenstein Dracula gambit remember if
your opponent plays Knight to c6 punish
him with this classy move like to be
fine and however black responds your
full point is awaiting on the board
thank you for watching my video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care